[Music]
now as I've mentioned a few times it is
it is Valentine's Day but there is a bit
of a problem this year actually the last
couple years with the economy in rough
shape a lot of people out there have to
stick to a tight budget when they buy
their Valentine's Day gifts okay they
have less money to spend so this is a
nice service we've been providing here
with some more money-saving
Valentine's Day tips is our prop master
bill tall bill take a pair of underwear
the staple of doily to it
boom lingerie
[Music]
here's bill with another tip take some
calamari put a piece on our finger boom
engagement
here's another one
take some grapes put them in a blender
boom why
[Applause]
boom aged 1
take a piece of pizza squeeze out the
grease boom massage oil
I'm tried the pizza idea it works guys
not well